i always loved maths
and i've always been fascinated by human
behavior as an undergraduate i studied
artificial intelligence and mathematics
at the university of edinburgh
it fused all of my interest it was
perfect
but then in my fourth year i got stuck i
really struggled
and started to suffer from imposter
syndrome
although i wanted to take my study
further i became scared i was incapable
i didn't think i would get picked by
oxford university but
i decided to give it a shot as the
course was so interesting
i couldn't believe it when i got
accepted as the opportunity became
reality
i also realized i will need help paying
for it i looked into funding and i
discovered the deepmind scholarship
the deepmind scholarship is aimed
specifically at people like me
from backgrounds underrepresented in ai
i never consider i was underrepresented
just by being a woman but when i started
thinking about my field
about the field of ai i soon realized
that that was true
so i decided to apply the first thing
deepmind did was spur me with my mentor
fariel bebani
who has done outstanding research in
reinforcement learning
uh so maybe we can check that out
speaking to ferial really made me
understand the importance and the need
for representation in ai
for our work to truly serve society as a
whole
we must consider the needs of everyone
you need a broader representation of
different groups
because without it there are crucial
aspects you won't think about
and that's because they have not been
hardwiring to you as a priority
with each background comes a different
focus
a different priority a different way of
seeing
it being with the other deep money
scholars at oxford
really brought this to life and it was
such a supportive environment among us
we had something that unified us because
of the scholarship program
and all of the support i received my
self-confidence has grown immensely and
now i believe in myself again
i feel empowered and that i can face
anything
looking to the future i have this
ambition that what i will do
will have a purpose higher than me and
serve society
working on ai is the answer to that it
can be applied to so many of the
problems that we face
like finding a solution to climate
change or improving health care
for anyone that is thinking about
applying i will say do it
don't underestimate the potential that
you have and the value of your unique
background
there is no one else like you out there
i am a deepmind scholar